só vocês acham que este ato é verdadeiro
ou não pessoas só com brilhou e deu meu
deus e agora a pessoa faça uma pergunta
o que será que o concludente ok vamos
ver eu quero que tudo vá então não vou
brincar solano que vocês vão tomar no c
p
antes de começar um vídeo só um fato
importante eu bebo café sem açúcar
já os cientistas dizem que o primeiro
café sem açúcar que a visita pelo
psicopata tem 90% de chances e psicopata
e eu acho que isso é mentira
deixaram-me kibutz matzuva pessoal e
quem fala a dar que sejam muito bem
vindos à má e zumbi eo normal pois não
sim vamos explicar então como está a
situação toda por como vocês viram ontem
vídeo pra quem viu né porque há muita
gente não só por favor trate bem as
notificações porque muita gente não está
a receber o vídeo ou recebe mais tarde
que foi o que aconteceu e não vê amarelo
em nome da instituição estava a cargo do
ministério do animado mas tudo isto
aumente nem só vocês posto o que é que
eu não gostar muito tempo e itanhaém eu
tenho culpa tava eu não vou culpar a
plataforma calmo hoje você que não possa
ser tanto de vídeos mais tempo quando eu
gosto
muita gente não sabe a notificação ou
acidente por um dia depois já as oito da
manhã que está tudo a dormir e se vocês
não deixarem o iraque nos vídeos ainda
mais não vão assumir não fixa um
cruzamento o pessoal lá teve o seguinte
à notificação e agora como explicar
então o vídeo passado que eu gostei pra
quem não viu o custeio como se fosse um
trailer controle e minha ida para uma
casa assombrada por acaso esta aqui e
está assombrada mesmo tem coisas aqui a
andar às vezes durante o primeiro tempo
às vezes tem outras coisas malucas
primeiro café sou psicopata 2008
só vocês também deixou para trás da
câmera já deixou a equipe porque isso
aqui tem que haver um empate entre 9 uma
novidade muito grande pra vocês pessoal
que já vai acontecer sábado dia 3 vocês
vão poder estar comigo metais e três
caixas do que a skype durante pescaria
isso é fantasia que faz 25 anos o
convidaram a minha voz e provar estar
muito importante
se gostar das coisas em cascais das 15
horas às 17 horas no hotel maksoud uma
foto ou um autógrafo no estudo faz
quiserem abraços e beijinhos mesmo b e
educação mas no pé não votaram e não
ainda por cima longe vai dar em 50% de
desconto em um boi de brinquedos muito
obrigado por tanta pressão comprar
coisas podem não ser a mim também se
quiserem que precisam ser alguém da
ferrari foi uma casa nova também é fixo
o que eu quis passar com esse vídeo
vamos agora dar muitas informações
muitas novidades portanto foi só até o
fim porque isso é um processo que está
em andamento e vocês precisam perceber o
que está a acontecer quando você está
bem sólida da colômbia e por
variadíssimas razões uma que eu não vou
explicar por que não vale a pena e
outras aquelas que vocês já sabem que eu
expliquei em vídeo atacou pode entrar lá
quem entrar em pessoas constantemente
dentro do jardim invadirem propriedades
portanto eu não me sinto seguro e
acabamos por ser do acaso e como vocês
sabem controlar a gente sabe quem
procurou casa sabe é muito complicado
arranjar casa assim para o dia e à noite
logo a simbi então nós andamos visitar
muitas casas dessas casas e esta casa
quando eu ouvi hoje em pé e esta casa é
df espera conteúdo do terror o tenhamos
feito mesmo assim assombrado e tal e dá
pra fazer essas coisas rituais quanto
contra o guarani já tem ficado por fazer
branco sob ordem dá pra fazer muita
coisa aqui com o terror mexe-mexe aqui
um pouquinho tanto aí eu não sei se esta
casa está realmente assombrada e eu nem
tenciono que inventar que ela está
assombrada fingir que não é fantasma da
final
eu não tenho que fazer isso aqui é minha
intenção é mesmo tentar e comprovar que
alguma coisa existe ao tentar ir em
busca de fantasmas ou do que quer que
seja mas não fazer com que as coisas
aconteçam o que é e se acontecer alguma
coisa aconteça o que acontecer não
existe é isso que eu quero fazer quero
nesse vídeo mostrei algumas imagens que
o próprio montei como se fosse mesmo
filme para saber a vossa opinião e muita
muita gente com medo que sim que querem
que eu vivo aqui nesta casa porque saiu
se vocês querem vocês querem que eu
morrer nem com um fantasma no gol eu sei
que vocês querem isso é preciso que
vocês pediram para eu viver aqui enfim
eu perguntei isso porque não sei se vou
ficar aqui nesta casa porque é uma casa
provisória e só enquanto não arranja uma
casa melhor em uma casa que me sinta
confortável
acho eu não sei se aqui sinto-me
confortável mas se vocês não estarão
neste contexto que eu irei fazer
controle e tal eu não sei só muita pena
ficar aqui mas aí é só uma ideia minha e
não comenta e mesmo muito sólida e
também 10
querem que eu faço aqui querem que eu
faça um ritual de shows em específico
querem que o uso do banheiro e já que os
tupi uram não sei como entendemos
daiichi e eu tenho é dos bons
comentários também vocês comentaram aqui
muita coisa muita coisa e buscar ser eu
vou responder que algumas coisinhas
muito rápido primeiro comentário já que
em destaque este sim mas sem freio foi
mesmo foi precisamente isso que eu quis
vir agora aqui neste vídeo porque eu não
quero fazer as coisas inventadas ok eu
quero ir em busca de estão encontrar eu
não encontrei
5 sou capaz de dar tudo para que você
cria um canal do terror ou faça vídeos
do corpo no seu canal principal aqui um
filme bastante sem muito vocês querem
percorrer e querem que volta às origens
dos garçons controle e tal mas eu acho
que há aqui uma coisa que vocês eu acho
que tenho vocês não percebem o que vocês
gostam eu vou explicar
eu acho que vocês não querem ver
propriamente terror eu acho que vocês
querem que uma justa e querem ver a
minha filiação assustar curto eu próprio
às vezes fazem terror é e assim um pouco
quando não assustam quando aquilo não
vai ter tanto medo que vocês também
acabam por não gostar
então eu acho que vocês preferem até
avaliação do cumprimento o conteúdo
origem se ok mas eu acho que nesta casa
e roubar muito susto mesmo mas vamos ver
oque é sexy mora e faz vídeos é a
mostrar a casa no estado foi de mostrar
em casa mas eu não vou fazer como
habitualmente faz que buscam é longa
casa dona tanabi junto não costuma fazer
nos vídeos vocês vão ver na casa e tal
mas como eu digo se este conteúdo não
desagradar eu não posso ficar muito mais
tempo aqui e por que eu estou
constantemente à procura de um sítio
mais grave mais especificamente por
conteúdo de terror portanto se não
desagradar muito que eu vou fazer aqui o
que causa sempre exploraram acabaram
equipas idéias aqui dentro eu talvez
comprar outra casa portanto não se
incomodem muita que é esta aqui é porque
nem eu próprio estou esperando se um
thriller de terror sem perceber porque é
mesmo era qualquer coisa se for morar
nessa casa assombrada toma muito cuidado
e opinion eu podia ocupo muito contigo
com um abraço um grande abraço pra mim
esses índices e não se preocupe comigo
porque estou me aquecedor da empirix
vantagem mas nós também caça vampiros
meu deus como uma ordem que o pescoço
então vou parte do vídeo você morar e
fazer ritual ou jogou hoje e
usa eu já não sei e não só fazer o que
escrevem mal eu não sei ler de o desafio
anel final cinema porque o que é isso
prêmio tipo que eu vou fazer um juízo
agora sim por dois anos porque aqui tem
coragem não dois anos não é muito eu eu
acho que eu nem vou ter conteúdo
suficiente para fazer aqui dentro da
casa por dois anos é assim é impossível
é sim uma espera que nós temos de fazer
muito bem eu vou explicar o que é o
clube mais do que vai ter quando vocês
fazem uma turnê em londres pelo que não
conhecido com a realidade do vídeo não
que não aconteceu em vídeo o cara eu
estiver comigo no meu canal deve ter
tipo 1 ou 2 vídeos o máximo ou seja
enquanto não são tão leves que chamou de
aumentar a tensão que podem não conhecer
bem conquistar dentro do vídeo mas tudo
para também acontece em vídeo aí podem
não ser pior
isto é como um tipo se ela me tornou nem
sabe quanto vocês vêem que o hambúrguer
tipo em cima tudo bonitinho tudo gostoso
ips de comer e depois quando você é
jovem caixa tem sim tudo feito não mas
vende parcial face bem fire vem um
hambúrguer bem feio não está tão bonito
contá lá em cima imagem isso não
conhecido de aumentar a imagem mas
também não é o clube vai porque aumentou
mostrar uma música eu posso estou
comendo realmente é o hambúrguer clique
vai com deus mostra um hambúrguer e
vocês vão comer um filé do país não é
mulher é ter um filme pois só fila
isso aqui com ele aprendeu que o
profissional ainda internet empresas
incentivou com o produto for vamos
aceitar chantagem mas eles vão ver
esquentaram a endemias única via pois
qualquer um emenda envio de xinhai vem
não sei não já não é muito melhor que eu
ficasse internet agora que incluiu
também um problema é que eles fantasma e
chutou internet toda forma o cidadão que
não tem medo não tem aqui em natal no
meio do campo não dá mas eu encontrei
que os comentários perguntas que o
viaduto na sala que apareceu no trailer
se é verdadeiro ou não mas é uma
pergunta curiosa porque eu não sei se
aquilo é verdade ou se é falta de
princípios disso o ciclo é mesmo a
cabeça de um [ __ ] real embalsamá vaga
com resino aquelas coisas que eu juntos
ela não sai agora continuam outras
perguntas que vocês também perguntou a
dar como isto fosse praia onde estão os
body jam de talvane e barbárie e é assim
que imagino prova documental é assim é
aqui perto esta casa tem uma fazenda uma
uma quinta onde tem vários animais tem
várias caras têm vacas há tempos
max eu sei que não é invulgar vacas na
época tendo muitas por aí mas nas vacas
daquela gente que nunca vieram muito
grande mesmo então eu pensei por um
golpe e que o banco e vão ser mais
político eu deixei lá por uma temporada
enquanto eu tenho que resolver a minha
vida mas eu estou muito feliz que sou eu
garantiu lá um dia destes vou fazer um
vídeo mostrar como é que estão o boj
está completamente recuperado pelos axel
equipe já sem as filhas todas tá ótimo
estou muito feliz mas vou estar em breve
a cair nos preocupa então eu acho que é
um riso mais ou menos feliz vocês não
viram estrelas que eu estou falando
horrores coisas em casa acontecer vamos
ver esse vídeo pra vocês perceberem eu
vou ficar aqui nesta casa e vou tentar
explorar um pouco do conteúdo do terror
mas só se eles não gostarem eu também
estou continue a aumentar a procura de
outra coisa que vai te dar certo aí não
se preocupem que não vai ser só de roupa
eu vou continuar com experiências e vou
continuar com o conteúdo é habitual
mesmo alternando um pouco aqui vou
tentar conquistar mais regularmente eu
sair eu tenho que fazer isso é o meu
trabalho é o meu compromisso com vocês e
os sonhos é complicado quando assistem e
problemas psicológicos
estava louca e não sexual eu sou
psicopata emitem controlar às vezes não
obedece um partido então tem que fazer
os vídeos do green um pouquinho vocês
têm que entender que eu não sou o
rompimento mas logo banda virgin taça
banho não conseguir andar tem que
treinar vamos ao que interessa pessoal
vamos mostrar então a cabeça do viaduto
assombrada agora aqui é estar solo não
se viável assombrado olha aquilo mas
agora falando sério e honesto muito medo
principalmente do dia porque os olhos
dela brilham e parece que está vivo
qualquer coisa funciona que é o espírito
é então só que você já se acham que é
verdadeiro acham que é falso pelo tokyo
parece bem verdade que tem mesmo assim
unb seu lado um carro vejam só o deus eu
vou tentar zoom e também primeiro
comparecimento ao vivo clique aqui ou
saiu cheio o o o que será que tem aqui
por dentro de um buraco é só isto
por exemplo se configure o que este já
tinha há muito tempo pelo que parece
eu vou lá pro quarto que o autor não é
voltar aqui nessa assombrada angela
portinho viária lá só vocês acham que
este ato é verdadeiro ou não
vejam só como brilhou e deu meu deus eu
não se conseguem ver em câmera mas é que
a ouvir voltar para si mesmo passo
importante e se tornou a vida era ok
e este pela que isso não faz muita
confusão é muito conhecida qualquer
coisa real é como se tivessem a tocar
num cabelo curto sabem é muito parecido
mesmo que brown também quer papel deus
paulo vi as marcas ela é muito parecida
com a da pista que eu eu sei muito bem
ver se vai dar ou não porque eu já
troquei muitas vezes no chifre do god
save sempre de ter ou não isso é que não
parece que seja uma maneira de códigos
assim e acho que sim acho que é uma
banda era eu acho que o título não é
verdade não tem aqui também umas
castanhas 1 pelo assim bem estranho que
ele também não parece brasileiro
portanto eu acho que é mais falso do
verdadeiro rock mas o pelé me foi dada e
agora o pessoal faça uma pergunta o que
será que eu tenho por dentro o que vamos
ver para crer que um buraco bem estranho
acho que só pra pendurar lá dentro é
muito duro e tentar enfiar o dedo aqui
também os parafusos muito tempo usado
por um texto que já é velotti ou uma
coisa muito dura e eu não sei que isto é
não faço a mínima idéia nem sei como é
que embora chamado o animal mas deve ser
com um verniz ou qualquer coisa que faça
não fica duro mas não me parece que seja
isso aqui não teme perdê lo e mesmo até
o dia que mudou
o anc e até mesmo perder é pelo menos a
pele o que eu acho que é um privilégio
ou tenha uma postura olha isso eu fui
libertado em maio onde isso não é mesmo
é mesmo para entender que uma costura o
o pessoal acha que é verdadeira sim e eu
vou querer ser atendente não parece mas
tenho me sentido centro o mesmo que
qualquer coisa dentro da boca
não sei não face da economia o que é
isso é falso porque não tem mesmo buraco
ali dentro e fecharão este aqui com
qualquer coisa mas normalmente quando
são embalsamados e eu acho que os pais
fazem aquilo - com tinta e pincéis de
pesca sombra que isso foi feito com
tinta é o livro foi feito com tinta por
claro que isso tem fica fechado é porque
o amor é difícil é que a boca mesmo
coisas vão estar aberto a um pouco
dentro mas estivemos aqui são muito
muito reais dentro do ouvido e ao em
algum buraco não parece que sim parece
que sim mas eu não vou tirar lhe o dedo
néné e curiosa esta postura aqui é assim
muito em breve como absorver o que tinha
dentro mas não vou fazer isso porque
ainda pode ter um fantasma entre uma
maldição sei lá eu não quero voltar isso
bom enfim só comentei o que vocês acham
que ele é verdadeiro mas um erro na
minha opinião ela é verdadeira mas tem
elementos falsos como é lógico que é
prazer mesmo enviar e tal mas prometo
que vocês acham isso querem ver algum
ritual começa a cabeça de veado e não só
também do parafuso eu estava já estava
em nosso lado no sítio espero que vocês
tenham gostado que decidiu que só sabem
como tem muitos quiserem que eu continuo
a viver aqui em casa é agora que já
perceberam um panorama todo em que os a
responder algumas perguntas já sabem
também dia 13 das 15 das 15 às 17 horas
em cascais por tanta pressão lá a tvm
também deixei muito mais não foi
inscrito no canal e escalou se fiquem
atentos porque vai sair novas medidas
até aí eles fiquem bem até a próxima